vision vous l'avez peut-être remarqué la
météo donne décidément le tournis
saperait les rigueurs de l'hiver le
printemps semble en avance on a frôlé
les 20 degrés à bordeaux les 17 degrés à
paris une douceur qui va continuer
jusqu'au week-end à la rochelle françois
privat à philippe rite aid pas encore la
grande foule sur la plage de la rochelle
mais des étudiants en rupture de cours
pour absences de profs s'octroie une
pause sportive sous un vif soleil l'a
fait l'été
vous n'avez pas osé mettre le maillot de
bain ben quand même pas non mais hésité
mais c'est parce qu'il aura fallu qu'on
vienne le chercher mais sinon je pense
que l'on a mis parce qu'ils sont quand
même super chaud on a pris des photos
tout à l'heure on va les envoyer à nos
votes pour les faire bisquer à deux pas
des célèbres pire sur le vieux port
pas un souffle de vent mais du monde sur
les terrasses ont frôlé 17 degrés alors
émerveillé d'avoir un temps aussi
magnifique on va se débrouiller pour
prendre mon temps voilà simplement les
vacances avant les vacances
pas de marque d'étonnement au sein de la
station rochelaise de météo france les
températures d'avril en février
un phénomène qui se produit en fait
régulièrement aujourd'hui on peut dire
que comédienne on a des bons de secteurs
reçu mme sur la façade atlantique qui
nous emmène donc de l'air
doux et
qui grâce à l'ensoleillement plus nous
amène des températures de l'ordre de
16 17 18 voire 18 degrés et le vent du
sud se maintiendra sur la côte
atlantique jusqu'à la fin de la semaine